it's great to be joined today by Lucian
Truscott who's a columnist for salon I
read your article Lucian called why
Trump lies with great interest and in
that article you point out some of the
similarities between how the current
president lies and how authoritarian
leaders of different countries lie in
order to influence the population let's
start there at the sort of most basic
level how would you characterize the
types of lies that we hear from Donald
Trump he's doing is you know the classic
authoritarian thing of trying to take
over the I guess you would call it in a
contemporary terms the news cycle the
dominate a news cycle and in countries
like Russia and Turkey and places like
that that is well you know anywhere
where there are authoritarian
dictatorships or fake democracies the
way that they typically do it is by
seizing the assets seizing the the means
of communication taking over newspapers
taking over television stations cable
networks and that sort of thing
that's not possible here because the the
government which Trump is the head of
can't own the means of communication in
fact the only means of communication and
the government does own is stuff like
Radio Free Europe and I'm pretty sure
there are federal laws in fact I know
there are federal laws against the
government propagandizing within the
confines of borders of the United States
so the way that Trump does it is with
the assistance of Fox News which is the
sort of house organ of the Republican
Party currently the house organ of the
Trump administration
dominating the trying to dominate the
news cycle every day with a weather
whatever their talking points are you
don't it's not very well understood but
but there's always been a system in
place with the Republican Party and
Republican operatives in Washington
where once once a a week on Wednesdays
they have a meeting at grover norquist's
house and they put together an agenda to
of what they're going to try to
accomplish for the week and the coming
week and then what what they're going to
talk about and then every day I don't
even know who does it but somebody at
the Heritage Foundation or someone lets
out talking points and they go out to
the congressmen and Senators they go out
to friendly lobbyists they go out to
political operatives that are that are
Republican political operatives and and
you'll see when you turn on the news in
the morning all of a sudden everybody is
talking about tax reform or everybody's
talking about infrastructure everybody's
talking about something else
yeah well recently in fact or even
seeing that with this that this it's
very clear that now a sort of concocted
robert muller attack is taking place
either as a pretext to his eventual
attempted firing or whatnot but you see
what clearly is a coordinated effort for
everybody to be on message it's
absolutely a coordinated effort Fox News
leads the way places like Drudge and
Limbaugh lead the way with it Fox News
picks up whatever kind of crap they
dribble out and then they run with it
and then these people that that that the
various networks call on to to speak for
the Republican Party or the friendly you
know a conservative you know Talking
Heads get on there and they open their
mouths and outcomes
you know this incredible party line I
mean it's you know when I was growing
the thing that's amazing to me is
I was growing up we were panic-stricken
about about the communist threat and
Soviet Russia and all that kind of stuff
and we were taught in school in history
class and in civics class that in the
Soviet state they have a system of
propaganda that propagandize is that
their own citizens to get their citizens
on board and then they put out
international propaganda that talks at
that veto in the Soviet days they talk
about what great harvests they just had
or new industries that they were
building and all this kind of stuff and
and and we laughed about it I mean it
was propaganda everybody knew it was
fake everybody knew it was lies you know
at the same time they were talking about
what a great harvest they had some news
some legitimate news source and in the
Soviet Union would get a picture of long
bread lines or long lines at a meat
store that only had one kind of meat for
the day and everybody knew it was a lot
and and now to see that kind of thing
replicated in this country is just
astounded I mean that's what gets me the
other thing the other element of this
that I've been talking about and I'd be
curious to see what your thoughts are
there are sort of like politician lies
as I described them which is selective
framing of a bill to get one or another
sort of outlook in terms of the economic
impact or whatever the case may be the
lies from Trump have been these sort of
clearly demonstrably false assertions
about the most basic elements of the
world around us and to many of us it
would seem what's the point of a lie
like that what's the point of a lie
that's so easily debunk Abul is there
some reason why those lies are useful to
the president I think I think he's on
automatic pilot about that I mean it's
you're talking about the difference
between spin and life spin has always
been a part of the American political
system you know you see spin every day
right now with this tax bill where
Republic's Republicans come out and say
it's a middle
class tax cut and and that's that's a
lie but there's but but there's some
little modicum of truth in there you
know that some middle-class people are
going to get a text everybody that
doesn't itemize because they get a
larger you know personal deduction it's
going to get a slight tax cut so so
though they're really spinning but the
kind of stuff that brung comes out
that's I mean the story that I'm working
on today is sort of refreezes this whole
question hacking thing of yeah meddling
in the election I went back through the
these stories about what actually
happened last year and it's absolutely
astounded all of this stuff was going on
in a fault and and every time the Trump
administer the Trump campaign Trump
transition opened its mouth they were
saying no no Russians we don't know any
Russians we've never talked to a Russian
we wouldn't know Trump Trump used to say
I've never talked to Putin I've never
made a phone call to Russia you know and
and it yeah those are not that's not
spinning
that's just inventing this reality that
they that they invent and then what's
really going on in in and then this kind
of full court press lying is it's the
way that Trump has always exercised
power the way that he exercised power as
a as a real estate guy was to sit down
with somebody where he's going to buy a
piece of property or he's gonna hire a
contractor to build something for him
and so forth and he would sit there and
a lie and lie and lie in order to get a
larger margin of profit in order to get
the thing built whatever his goal was
the way he got it was by lying and
that's in the that's in Tony Schwartz's
book that he wrote with Twitter opera
for drop the art of the deal yeah Tony
Schwartz you know you know short-handed
it as kind of creative exaggeration
or something like basically what he was
doing was just sitting there lying all
day long and what he did was run this
company the company actually built
buildings it put glass in windows and
put floors down and and put in plumbing
and electricity and all of that kind of
stuff
but it was really built on this towering
inferno of Lies and-and-and he doesn't
know any other way to go about it I mean
you look at that the Washington Post
compendium of lies that they put out a
little while ago
sixteen hundred and thirty-eight or
something like that
it's five lies a day you know it's it's
some astounding number and I don't I
don't think that he knows anything any
other way to to exercise power there's
this term in debate called the Gish
gallop which is the idea that in a
debate with a sort of limited amount of
time allocated if candidate a or
participant a just throws so much stuff
out there even if it's all absolutely a
spin or lies that by sort of the
constraints of the time of the debate
their opponent is not going to be able
to refute all of them and some of those
unrefuted lies might consciously or
subconsciously sort of become ingrained
as truth in the minds of the audience is
there an element of that that's going on
because news outlets including cable
news paper is independent media whoever
you can only debunk so much or you end
up spending your entire time just
pointing out in what ways Donald Trump
is not telling the truth is that sort of
a Gish gallop of Lies that Donald Trump
is benefiting from yeah I was a debater
in high school many many many years ago
I'm a knight I used to run up against
that all the time especially from these
guys networks that were championship
debaters they their their main strategy
was to just blanket their five-minute
period or set up stuff with whatever
period that they had to talk or one of
the two guys had to talk they just say
they put forth so many assertions and so
many so-called back
then you were supposed to get up and
were futile and and the way I dealt with
that was not it was to get up and
completely ignore what they'd said I
wouldn't refute anything what I used to
do was look at the judges and say you
know I'd say I don't know what those
guys just said do you know what they
said you understand any of that stuff I
don't understand it so let's look at
this let's look at this from with a new
set of eyes and let's try to figure this
out lets you and me try to figure this
out well I won one debate after another
doing there because because the judges
couldn't understand what the hell they
were talking about and then the way you
defang that it is putting out a
counter-narrative that you know that
simplifies whatever the subject is that
you're talking about and and and and you
take over the you take over the debate
that way the problem with the democrats
have is you know you know they're open
to complaints all the time the democrats
don't have a message yeah you know not
only do they not have a message they
don't have a messenger they don't have
anybody that can stand up there and say
golly we just listened to all this crap
that they came out with about the tax
bill today you know do you do you get it
do you get what that pass-through is do
you understand what you know what one of
these LLC's is and all that kind of
stuff no I don't either so let's sit
down and try to figure out who this
thing is really good for who'll it
really benefits and who it doesn't
benefit and then you take the debate
over and and put out a limited very
limited number of facts that are that
are in your favor and that's how you win
these kind of things
I just amazes me that the Democrats you
know don't have anybody that's got that
kind of ability a last thing I want to
touch on Lucien you mentioned in your
article that Donald Trump is using lies
to keep himself from being removed from
office can you talk a little bit about
what you mean by that and whether it
will ultimately be an effective way of
keeping himself in
office well I mean he's you know the the
big line that they've pushed spread from
the beginning is the threat to his being
in office is the Russia inquiry and and
you can watch this kind of descending
staircase of lies if they put out about
that it began with way back during the
campaign we don't know anything about
Russia we don't know any Russians you
know what is this Russia thing then it
went into Sean Spicer standing up in
front of that you know the White House
press corps and say and literally saying
I mean all this stuff has gone down the
memory hole but literally standing up
there and saying the Trump campaign in
the transition had no contacts with
Russia we don't know any motions and
then when every single contact came out
and was exposed it was oh well that was
just that they were just talking about
they were wishing each other
Merry Christmas or without you know and
then so it's it's this descending
staircase of lies and and and you know
they just keep revising the lie over and
over again and that I think at this
point I think that really that's all
Trump and his people can think of to do
you know they don't have any they don't
have any alternative the alternative
would be the only alternative would be
as if none of that stuff happened but it
did happen and there's evidence that it
happened and there's testimony that it
happened now and they've got cooperating
witnesses that are telling prosecutors
that happen so but so the you know the
lie thing has been working in the in a
in the politics of it but it's now run
up against this brick wall of a criminal
investigation and you know you can look
and see as well as I can what happens
when one of these idiots like Flynn or
Papadopoulos or any of the rest of them
actually sit there and tell a lie to an
FBI agent or a federal prosecutor yeah
getting died
we are quickly seeing that list of
indict E's grow lucien Truscott he is a
columnist for salon check out his piece
why Trump lies thanks so much for
talking to us about this I appreciate it
okay thanks a lot bye